what we're going to do in this video is
continue talking about uniform circular
motion and in that context we're going
to talk about the idea of period which
we denote with a capital T or we tend to
denote with a capital T and a very
related idea and that's of frequency
which we typically denote with a
lowercase F so you might have seen these
ideas in other context but we'll just
make sure we get them and then we'll
connect it to the idea of angular
velocity in particular the magnitude of
angular velocity which we've already
seen we can denote with a lowercase
Omega
since I don't have a little arrow on top
you could view it just the lowercase
Omega as the magnitude of angular
velocity but first what is period and
what is frequency
well period is how long does it take to
complete a cycle and if we're talking
about uniform circular motion or a cycle
is how long does it take if this is say
some type of a tennis ball that's
tethered to a nail right over here and
it's moving with some uniform speed a
period is well how long does it take to
go all the way around once so for
example if you have a period of one
second this ball would move like this
one second two seconds three seconds
four seconds that would be a period of
one second if you had a period of two
seconds well it would go half the speed
you would have one second two seconds
three seconds four seconds five seconds
six seconds and if you went the other
way if you had a period of half a second
well then it would be one second two
seconds and so your period would be half
a second it would take you half a second
to complete a cycle and so period is the
unit of period is going to be the second
the unit of time and it's typically
given in seconds
now what about frequency well frequency
literally is the reciprocal of the
period so frequency is equal to 1 over
that one a little bit neater one over
the period and one way to think about it
is well how many cycles can you complete
in a second period is how many seconds
does it take to complete a cycle while
frequency is how many cycles can you do
in a second so for example if I can do
two cycles in a second one second two
seconds three seconds then my frequency
is two cycles per second and the unit
for frequency is sometimes you'll hear
people say just per second so the unit
sometimes you'll see people just say an
inverse second like that or sometimes
they'll use the shorthand Hz which
stands for hurts and hurts is sometimes
substituted with cycles per second so
this you could view as seconds or even
seconds per cycle and this is cycles per
second now with that out of the way
let's see if we can connect these ideas
to the magnitude of angular velocity so
let's just think about a couple of
scenarios let's say that the magnitude
of our angular velocity let's say it is
pi radians pi radians per second so if
we knew that what is the period going to
be pause this video and see if you can
figure that out
so let's work through it together so
this ball is going to move through pi
radians every second so how long is it
going to take for it to complete two pi
radians because remember one complete
rotation is two pi radians well if it if
it's going pi radians per second it's
gonna take it two seconds to go to pi
radians and so the period here let me
write it the period here is going to be
equal to two seconds now I kind of did
that intuitively but how did I actually
manipulate the Omega here well one way
to think about it the period I said look
in order to complete one entire rotation
I have to complete two pi radians so
that is
entire cycle is going to be two pi
radians and then I'm going to divide it
by how fast what my angular velocity is
going to be so I'm gonna divide it by in
this case I'm gonna divide it by PI
radians pi and I could write it out PI
radians per second I'm saying how far do
I have to go to complete a cycle and
that I'm dividing it by how fast I am
going through the angles and that's
where I got the two seconds from and so
already you can think of a formula that
connects period and angular velocity
that period period is equal to remember
two pi radians is an entire cycle and so
you just want to divide that by how
quickly you are going through the angles
and so that there will connect your
period and angular velocity now if we
know the period it's quite
straightforward to figure out the
frequency so the frequency is just 1
over the period so the frequency is
we've already said it's 1 over the
period and so the reciprocal of 2 PI
over Omega is going to be Omega over 2
pi over 2 pi and in this situation where
the period was 2 seconds if you don't
even know what Omega is and someone says
the period is 2 seconds then you know
that the frequency the frequency is
going to be 1 over 2 seconds 1 over 2
seconds or you could view this as being
equal to 1/2 you could sometimes see the
units like that which is kind of per
second but I like to use Hertz and in my
brain I say this means 1/2 cycles per
second so one way to think about it it
takes 2 seconds to complete if I'm doing
PI radians per second my ball here is
going to go 1 second 2 seconds 3 seconds
4 seconds and you see just like that my
period is indeed 2 seconds and you also
see that in each second remember any
second I cover pi radians well
pi radians is half a cycle I complete
half
a cycle per second